joining us now former White House press
secretary Sean Spicer the hills Joe
concha former president of the National
Correspondents Association Fox News
chief national correspondent and Henry
let's start with you Sean Spicer you
know it's fascinating if anybody ever
leaked any of this from any special
counsel and to the New York Times
another Isana anonymous source thing it
would be against a Democrat you and I
both know they'd be such an outcry in
the country about that absolutely I
think that what you're seeing now is is
definitely concerning and I understand
why the president wants to get this
wrapped up we've seen it go over and
over again for the better part of a year
no evidence has come forward everything
gets leaked out that's to save disfavour
rule to the president
and it's about time that that they fish
or cut bait the president and the White
House have been very forthcoming with
individuals information and it's about
time that we either wrap this thing up
or allow the president to because
presidents doing great things and has to
move on on the agenda in this country
what was your opinions of mr. Comey what
does it matter he can fire him for any
reason Joe konchem well I think we see
Sean with the behavior of James Comey on
the book tour terms of getting personal
about the president if you look at
Brennan's Twitter account and just
scroll down it you see a highly partisan
the triolic person on there and it's
hard to believe that when he was running
the CIA that he actually was able to
separate all those feelings and knew his
job without that sort of partisan
thinking and obviously clapper who's now
a CNN contributor same thing so I think
this is very disturbing that you have
all these top officials engaging in
partisan behavior and as for the leaks I
mean we keep hearing that Muller is
running a straightforward clean
investigation then he'll own it into the
pages of the New York Times exactly I'd
love to know when you point Andrew
Weissman withheld exculpatory evidence
twice was overturned nine zero in the
Supreme Court put four Merrill
executives in jail for a year overturned
by the Fifth Circuit and put tens of
thousands of of Anderson accounting
workers out of work and blow everything
and get appointed by Muller it ought to
tell you everything you need to know
that Henry quick question on the
respondents thinner why would president
trump ever go I think he's right I think
this whole thing is dead goodbye isn't
it's buried now I used to think he might
go next year ahead of his reelection
battle try to have an olive branch but
your I think ur right now that he will
never go that was destroyed on Saturday
night Sarah Sanders was treated horribly
the correspondent sociation invited her
basically into our home for dinner and
she was personally viciously attacked
and I think it's unlikely the president
will go pardon me and I think that I've
spoken a lot of reporters who say that
the Association played right into the
president's hands and that's why he was
outside the Beltway talking to the
people and inside the beltway he had
these elites you know sort of you know
beating up on Sarah Sanders and I think
it was a big big mistake all right
if I can't it's absolutely right I mean
if if this was a celebration of what the
media thinks is the celebration of the
First Amendment I hate to see how they'd
celebrate the fourth of July there was
no invocation they gave CNN Award right
off the bat on debunked information they
attacked the the the comedian made
derogatory comments about the tragedy on
the Southwest Airlines the the the vile
and disgusting language they used on
about abortion victims was just so out
of bands I don't think I think what
yesterday was the exposure of what
really is the problem that exists right
now and I hope that going forward not
only do we re-examine the need for this
dinner but a lot of folks in the media
understand the concerns that especially
conservatives have with things like this
if this doesn't end the White House
Correspondents Dinner for this president
I don't know what would but I'll tell
you another thing this garbage from the
New York Times tonight absolute garbage
no attorney will ever let this president
sit down with Robert Muller now it's
gonna go on for a year it's all
executive privilege and Muller drove
this as I predicted he would when he
hired his hit team of partisans Joe well
the I think that sums it up Shana in
terms of smaller in terms of again all
these top officials now being exposed
especially James clapper being shown to
have lied about leaking information to
the media and I think he has some
answers too
they answer some questions on Capitol
Hill about this Peter King mentioned on
this network earlier that they met that
may very well happen what's in your mind
that Henry this is not going to hold the
smell test I think it's unlikely the
president will ever sit down you're
right there was a time he thought I
thought he would but this list of
questions suggests they're still
pursuing collusion even though there's
no evidence and the cousins and dozens
of questions it's unlikely I'll ever sit
down ever all right guys good to see you